okay so demons run when a good man goes
to war what angels do that was a really
stupid intro hey everybody Merry
Christmas
it's just I'm not doing anything special
for Christmas on the channel it just
happens to be the day that the thing I
was already gonna do which is this is
coming out so whoo uh so yeah let's talk
about a good man goes to war sort of a
mini finale
midway through series six and it I have
a lot of good memories about this one I
liked it immediately when it aired but
it's also one of those ones that going
back and re-watch again I wanted I
wanted to try and take the nostalgia
goggles off at least a little bit and
try and look at it with fresh eyes if I
could at all and I really can't I mean I
love what I love about this thing and
there is so much I love that it opens
with Rory getting to be a freakin badass
I loved Amy's performance especially the
grief and the pain when she realizes
that she has lost her daughter and they
she plays that amazingly well like that
that chokes me up that got me the amount
of directions that Matt Smith has to go
in terms of channeling you know anger
triumph and you know having his his
little fun moments but then his
frustration his confusion he's got a lot
to jumble and he has to change gears
really quickly sometimes even in the
same scene and he pulls it off really
well we get the introduction of Jenny
Strax and vastra I like the three of
them quite a bit so that's a that's a
good thing for me and my book Strax
especially Strax I think will
see what I think about him revisiting
him later but his introduction here
[ __ ] perfect this this war combat
obsessed Sontaran you know telling
people don't slump it's bad for your
spine oh that's that's great
and plus you know fun callbacks with
dorium and with the with the pirates and
Danny Boy felt mildly contrived I think
that's only because the Spitfires in
space felt contrived even in the episode
they appeared in but you know why not
bring him to the party sure let's go for
that uh and there's just a really good
there's such a sense of triumph in the
first half and then such a sense of way
something's wrong something it's gonna
come apart and then it does and just the
bottom drops out of the thing it's such
a ride and then of course we have the
reveal of river and who she is and I
know some people claim to have called it
in advance I absolutely didn't now
that's part of that is I'm not I don't
spend a ton of time trying to
preemptively unravel mysteries
especially around characters identities
because for me if I don't care about the
character as they're presented to me
then it doesn't matter who they turn out
to be and I did like River I've always
liked rivers so I was invested enough in
that and I'm not really a fan theory
person in the first place I don't I
don't go to those kinds of sites or
forums or subreddit or what-have-you so
there are probably plenty of people who
either figured it out on their own or
came across somebody else who spoiled it
because they said hey I think it's this
I managed to avoid all that
so the reveal of river of river being
Amy and Rory's daughter they caught me
completely off guard and I loved it
I thought that was great and it it
really did feel like it fit not in a
this answer so many questions right but
know this raises a whole lot more
questions but at the same time like that
yeah that feels right and I love the way
it's revealed with the translation of
the thing that Amy had been given
that this soldier had stitched melody
pawns name but she's from the this
forest region where there are no ponds
there's only a river so she couldn't
stitch pond she stitched River and
melody song they're not complete
synonyms but they're close enough that
that was what she wrote and that's what
the translation came back as that was a
really cool reveal dug that I still did
that dig it a lot Madame Kovarian works
for me pretty well as a villain in terms
of being able to play the scheming and
then the gloating she's very good at the
gloating does that quite well there are
a few hiccups in this thing I'm not
necessarily sure there are things that
I'd forgotten or if they were just
things that didn't bother me as much
before there are a couple one of which
I've called out before in other videos
talking about I think it was the video I
did on queer mortality rates so the
token let's kill a nameless character to
establish that people can die thing
happens to be one half of a gay couple
who wasn't even granted a name he's just
the fat one - with that isn't because
he's gay or one half of a gay couple I
don't think any of this was really
necessary in the first place and I
actually think it kind of undercuts what
goes on later that they established as
part of the opening thing that the
headless monks are a in fact headless
and be take off people's heads to make
them one of their own I think that would
have worked much better as a reveal when
the when the colonel takes the hoods
down and we see for the first time oh
crap they really have no heads and then
when they take Dorian's head and you
realize oh they can just do that to
people I think that would have worked
much better as a surprise later on so
I'm annoyed at this moment a because yes
it is the needless killing of a gay
character but like it's a needless
killing of a character period because
the reveal at that point the story
doesn't actually help and
actually come to think of it I think the
Headless monks are kind of a weak spot
overall it's not that they're bad
they're kind of a neat idea it's a cool
name for sure but they don't contribute
anything not really there's nothing that
they do that actually has any impact on
the story that couldn't have been done
by just some kind of elite sort of
soldier or like really anything they're
it's a filler it's a stand-in it's we
want to have something new here what can
it be but they're no more impactful than
the smilers were in the beasts below or
the whisper men turned out to be in name
of the doctor later on down the line
there it's just a placeholder and they
were cool enough idea that I kind of
wish they weren't being just tossed in
and then never picked up on again now
that I'm sure there's that much more you
could do with them but it's a cool
enough idea that I kind of wish they'd
been in a story where what they are and
how they operate was a bit more central
whereas here they're just they're just
slot it in for to have a minor variety
versus the soldiers with guns but they
still don't really contribute much of
anything because they can still
apparently do long-range combat and like
that's it they're not bad they don't
drag the thing down but they don't
contribute anything either they just
kind of eat up space and that is a bit
of an annoyance for me with them and
that's probably the biggest criticism I
I have of this is that there's a bit of
time sunk into these villains I guess
that just doesn't need to be there now I
also kind of want to touch on the over
arch how this fits into the overarching
story that's going on especially in
series 6 at this point which is this
idea that the doctor has been around for
so long and has dropped in on so many
planets intervene in so many conflicts
that there are
people so afraid of what he's capable of
that they are prepared to do just about
anything to try and stop him not
necessarily because they think he's evil
though I think they play that up as if
that's their angle on him but just
because he gets to go around do whatever
he wants if he decides what he wants to
do is take us down he can this this is
not okay it's like having the sword of
Damocles hanging over your head the
whole time they want to get rid of that
and that makes a certain amount of sense
and this is probably for me we'll see
how I feel going forward this is
probably for me about the where it Peaks
this whole idea of the doctors
reputation getting so big that it
actually creates a problem for him
because I've talked about the doctors
reputation before I'm not a huge fan of
the doctor being so well known so
recognized that he is in the myths of
countless people I seems like the whole
frame universe knows who he is
and I don't like that in general just
because I don't like the feel that it
gives to him for me the doctor is not a
mythic figure be it a mythic destroyer
or a mythic Savior the doctor is
somebody who shows up and helps if he
can and again this is not about
logistics I get the logistical argument
he's traveling all over time and space
he's gonna pop up in so many places so
many people's history that he stories
will be told about him and then they'll
meet other civilizations who have their
stories about the doctor delay I get it
I get how it can happen I just don't
like the feel that it lends to the
character in the show so this is not a
logistical issue for the love of God do
not leave a comment saying oh but it
makes sense that he has such a
reputation because he would I know that
I'm not arguing logistics I'm saying I
just don't like it that got a little
uppity it's just I've explained that
repeatedly and people still try and make
an argument to me that's supposed to
convince me and they do it completely on
basis of logistics which I get I
explaining that to me it's not gonna
change my opinion anyway as I said this
might kind of be the tipping point for
me a little bit because I do think there
is it since they have already gone to
the point of the doctor having a
reputation this big where he can
basically just tell people who know who
he is whether it is the Vashta Nerada or
the atraxi to back off or run and it
works they kind of hinted in series 5
with the Pandorica that certainly his
enemies will have a reason to hold
together but now it's taken one step
further with the idea that people who
have not even met him who have never
been challenged by him who have never
had conflict with him directly are still
afraid of him there is some interesting
stuff to be mined from that but I think
this is about as far as my tether was
willing to go on this whole issue
because while I and I think a lot of it
has to do with the strength of this
story conceptually this is actually
probably slightly past the point I would
have ever wanted it to go but the
execution in this specific episode is so
good that I'm willing to go with it this
far but from here this particular issue
is gonna it's gonna be a downhill slide
for me I suspect that's my memory but
again like things get reassessed as I do
this rewatch so maybe it won't bother me
as much but it really does lend a
completely different feel to especially
the the season arc focused episodes
definitely for the remainder of of
Smith's run and most of Moffitt's so I'm
not I'm not thrilled that we've kind of
hit the the high point of this and is
all gonna be downhill from here or at
least I expect it's going to be based
off my memory again we'll see but
zeroing back in on this episode itself
doctors great I love Amelia pond get
your coat like that all the confidence
of that I love it I like the supporting
cast everybody's giving great
performances it's just really solid
accepting basically the Headless monks
which aren't even a drag on it they just
aren't contributing much to the
proceedings and that's about the worst
thing that I can say about it looking at
the episode in isolation looking overall
like it's is continuing a trajectory
that I'm not a huge fan of but you know
is what it is and we'll deal with that
as it comes up in future episodes next
ones let's kill Hitler I'm gonna be
really curious about that one largely
because my memory of it was it was fine
and I had fun but I keep seeing a pop up
on people's lists of like worst episodes
of the modern era and I don't know if
something just bothers other people that
it didn't for me or if there is an issue
I missed because I haven't rewashed it
in a while but I'll be curious to see if
I end up being kind of a low-key
defender of that one or not depending on
what I get out of the rewatch we'll see
that'll be that'll be in the new year
huh
so I'll be back with more of these in
2020 so thanks so much for tuning in
folks good man goes to war what do you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are dropping down the comments let's
talk about a bunch of stuff to do like
subscribe share this video support me on
patreon Oh wouldn't that be nice plus
links other stuff besides click on them
they'll take you places or I don't you
don't have to because at the end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
Merry Christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]